sinless person I mean to preach one
sinless person do you know theet
Muhammed sin no he sin yeah one sin
person
muham okay seek
forgiveness because no he doesn't
because why Jesus said father forgive us
so he s forgiveness
to so Jesus in the Bible he s
forgiveness he has a sinless life
brother you have you come to my
territory this is UN preaching
so listen if you want to feel me preach
this I'm Jud Jesus Christ said I am the
way I am the truth and I am the life no
one comes to father but by so by
Jesus the B I am the way I am said only
was sinless he had power to forgive sin
but Muhammad had no power to forgive he
forg Muhammad said why did he woman wait
wait step by m step by step look he
agress
now step by step M Prophet Muhammad
someone came to him and he said your s
be forgiven Jesus
Christ to be to does that mean doesn't
mean that that's in the Bible for okay
so can you go forgive sin Jesus forgave
sin okay so why you got in the Bible
said Stone the adult woman in the old
step by step to me he said to the adult
woman neither do I condemn your
wom I tell you why I tell you why I tell
you why are you coming in is preaching I
you want to use as
cover the
Allah and he Jesus the one question
you you you do Jesus
Christ the question which is on the
heart
ofan he's a liar and the Bible children
the have the same Quran as you the same
Quan have
discuss never said you are killing
children because Quan They never said
that but the Jewish people say they
killing because the in the Old Testament
in the Old Testament is to kill children
you see how they are slaves of je people
they slaves of
the the K of
children
why see how he's doing again I will
challenge
you
must children
you my question why did mhad order
just she was she was
breastfeeding she was
a when a man killed her her so
Muhammad just because she wrote a poem
against Muhammad Muhammad didn't like
criticizing him and he order leave speak
watch can I speak now okay now but you
see I don't debate you debate speak I
don't debate you know I'll tell you why
let me speak you're as Prophet mammam
because if you believe kill woman is
kill woman evil or not
is children raping
womis rap women Isis killed the women of
my country and you and they they had the
same Quran on the flag they
had all say Allah in this part over and
over we see
fromb
the I said you Muslim are worshiping the
same God you have the same Quran so as
much as Hamas is terrorist you are a
terrorist is killing children good or
bad why Hamas killing children okay I'll
tell you what because from the Bible the
B Li show show me
the3
liar so he says in the Quan says to kill
children the Bible in the Bible K babies
in the
Bible watch this in the Bible it says
kill children I'm a l speaking the truth
listen no no I'm a l speaking the truth
I'm here to pre the goel I'm not no no
no no I'm a l speaking the truth in the
Bible to Children the Bible look he's
that defend the Bible I don't care Bible
baby
chck
ch
Z slave you're a z slave don't touch me
don't touch me don't touch me don't
touch me again don't tou me don't tou
don't touch me have right don't touch me
don't touch me
yes don't tou
me not allow to touch me Li liar yes by
by what I did is with me Z slave you're
a z slave you're a Zion
slave in the Bible says to kill children
and he was not even able to condemn the
Zionist to show you that are slaves
these people the Christians not every
Christian the Christian extremist they
are slaves of the Zionist the Indian
woman she was worshiping a cow now she's
worshiping a man and she's raising the
flag of the Zionist look at that Subhan
Allah but to show in the Bible says to
kill babies and children Prophet
Muhammad said in the war the battle in a
war don't kill women don't kill children
don't don't even kill a scholar a man in
his church the man who's in church don't
kill him look to the prophet Muhammad's
teaching all Christians and Jewish
people out there and look to the
teaching of the Bible kill woman kill
infant kill this kill that Subhan Allah
so I was ask him is killing a woman good
or bad cuz even I say ice are doing it
okay now to criticize Isis you have to
believe something uh different than them
because how are you going to criticize
Isis for killing woman when youself
believe killing a woman is okay in your
Bible so the Isis for following the
Bible I'm telling you and any Christian
who agree with me come here I expose you
not speak to you today I'm going to
expose these AAS who are watching with
our brother and sisters dying in
Philistine and they don't even saying a
word this a li extremist Christians not
every Christian by the way because Islam
again look Islam teach us to be what to
be just you know there are some
Christians out there they speaking out
you know you know they're showing the
hypocrisy of the Liars that how come
when Putin was killing people in Ukraine
everyone say Putin evil man is a
terrorist but when when this Zionist
terrorist nanyu killing TR and phe
everyone say no they defending
themselves even Pi Morgan this he saying
they defending themselves from what from
children from a baby that's 5 months
old but this is the outcome of F that
Allah expose people because why it's
called
when you put a gold Into the Fire to see
if it's real or fake you see so in the
time of fan Allah expose the real ones
Allah distinguish the real ones with the
fake ones okay but my dear brothers and
sisters protesting is no solution protes
against Quan the solution is make Dua
pray or try to help them with sending
money and make sure the money is going
to the right people okay by protesting
shouting screaming Muslim woman
screaming that's not from the the
Islamic teaching Muslim woman should not
be screaming
shouting or free mixing with the
man so we have to be careful we don't go
we don't we don't we don't remove
oppression with Injustice and sin you
understand and whatever whatever I done
when I pushed him by law by British law
French law Chinese law law I'm allowed
to do it you know cuz he's not allowed
to touch me I have a right to defend
myself because I was sent to
hospital I was sent to hospital for two
weeks liar Li against Prophet Muhammad
wasallam this Christian guy he cannot
even debate with Isis Isis will refute
him because is would say okay if you
believe killing woman and children is
bad in the Bible God said to kill women
and children so is it bad or good you
see but no one speaks about it I'm not
sure if some of you saw there was a guy
in in Holland so he was non-muslim so he
got the Bible he got the Bible but he
covered it with the quran's cover and he
sent people to read about killing
children killing woman and therefore it
was Quran so they say look this book is
evil you know and then they showed them
this is not Quran it's a Bible you see
some of them said no no no no no no look
Subhan Allah that shows you some people
that are
hypocrites so we have to learn our de my
dear brothers and sisters learn your de
study study that's advice to you as well
when need to speak our politics we speak
but we're don't going to make our
subject every single day politics
politics because when you die Allah will
not ask me about how come you did not
have philistine have the ability but
Allah will ask about the prayer and ask
about Allah will ask you about your
fasting leave him come there's a camera
he push
me take him take
him by law I'm allowed to push him yeah
by
law defense he pushed me you're not
allowed to put your
handd